[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent loi européenne sur la liberté
des médias le Sénat rappelle ces lignes
rouges réunie le 14 décembre 2023 la
commission des affaires européennes a
rappelé son soutien à l'objectif de la
proposition de règlement européen sur la
liberté des médias visant à renforcer la
liberté et l'indépendance des médias et
protéger les journalistes tout en
rappelant les lignes rouges du Sénat ce
texte qui a fait l'objet d'un accord
politique provisoire entre les
c-législateurs Européens contribuera à
préserver le pluralisme du paysage
médiatique européen à garantir son bon
fonctionnement et à renforcer la
protection de l'État de droit dans un
contexte international et européen où
celui-ci est parfois remis en cause
le Sénat n'est pas étranger à son
élaboration puisque les institutions
européennes ont tenu compte de son avis
motivé du 11 décembre 2022 appelant au
respect du principe de
subsidiarité le Sénat avait alors appelé
la Commission européenne à revoir sa
copie pour respecter les cadres
nationaux de régulation il est en effet
indispensable qu'une harmonisation
législative européenne laisse toute
l'attitude aux États-membres de
maintenir des normes plus élevées et de
continuer à développer leur propres
réglementation des médias en France il
existe déjà deux grandes lois
républicaines très solides la loi du 29
juillet 1881 sur la liberté de la presse
et la loi du 29 septembre 1986 sur la
liberté de communication
audiovisuelle concernant l'article 4 sur
la protection des journalistes et de
leurs sources la commission des affaires
européennes a appelé là aussi au respect
des principes de subsidiarité et de
proportionnalité les questions de
sécurité nationale relèvent de la
compétence des États-membres et non pas
de l'Union
européenne les États-membres sont déjà
tenus par les traités de respecter les
droits de l'homme et la liberté de la
presse sur le financement du service
public le Parlement européen a également
suivi les préoccupations du Sénat sur la
nécessité d'un financement non seulement
stable et suffisant mais aussi et
surtout prévisible transparent
indépendant impartial et pérenne la
commission des affaires européennes
restera vigilante sur le texte
définitivement adopté par l'Union
européenne
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du
[Musique]
Sénat